well I've taken you to Canada to
Guantanamo Bay but this time it really
looks like I pulled the short straw
because I'm here in the Motor City
welcome to Detroit
Detroit it's become a bit of a punchline
in this country but you have to ask
yourself how did one of the wealthiest
cities in the country become this
Detroit used to be the city with the
highest median household income of
anywhere in the country and now it
ranked 66th out of 68 it also had some
of the highest crime rates unemployment
rate and lowest graduation rates of
anywhere in the USA in a nutshell
Detroit sucks but why oh that's why I
forgot well to start it's no secret that
Detroit is run entirely by leftists
every single mayor of Detroit since 1961
has been a liberal it is the city of
entitlement programs leftists always
tout their policies as a way to help the
poor and give our fellow man a leg up
well how's that working out for them and
how did it get this way
it all started with Mayor Jerome
Cavanaugh elected in 1961 he expanded
the role of government in Detroit to an
unprecedented level particularly under
President Lyndon Johnson's presidency
with the model Cities program what's
that you've never heard of the model
Cities program well I'll show you
and the model Cities program is
considered by many to be the first great
step in central urban planning what
happened was they pumped four hundred
million dollars into a nine mile square
radius of Detroit the area that you see
here in order to make an exemplary city
for the rest of the USA to follow and of
course that sort of set a trend in
motion where Detroit ended up getting
hundreds of dollars in every single
federal bailout loan or grant that you
can possibly imagine
really Detroit is the poster boy for
leftist policies at work now clearly
they didn't succeed in creating a model
city but the government did succeed in
creating an entirely state depend in the
city which many people think was their
goal in the first place and that allowed
the government to tell people in this
city what they could build or they could
build it which businesses would stay
open which businesses would close and of
course in exchange for that stringent
government control they promised them
things like education training health
care more entitlement programs smells
funny speaking of Education how to
Detroit schools stack up there certainly
isn't any lack of funding here in
Detroit a students of Detroit receive on
average eleven thousand one hundred
dollars per student compare that to the
national average of 9600 yet Detroit
students enjoy graduation rate of
actually twenty five percent and a sad
fact of the matter is that a student of
Detroit has a higher chance of ending up
in prison than graduating high school
and you have to ask yourself well how
have the oh so powerful teachers unions
of Detroit's failed to students the
truth is they have been refusing to bend
on policies for years that would benefit
the students including merit-based pay
increased teacher to student ratios
giving incentives to better teachers or
of course the school choice program that
we've spoken about here at PJTV and it's
been a tremendous success wherever it's
been implemented across the country
could it be that the teachers unions
aren't really designed to help the
students but the unions of course public
education isn't the only place in
Detroit where unions get to flex their
power also plants and factories like
these are what made the big three
American auto companies Detroit the envy
of the rest of the industrialized world
for so long after World War two cars are
being produced rapid
léa people were buying in Detroit was
prosperous which makes you wonder what
happened it's no secret that American
auto companies have required federal
bailout after bailout and liberal
politicians will tell you that that is
because of poor management and not on a
fuel-efficient cars they'll say that
when the gas prices rose the economy
crashed and people wanted smaller more
fuel-efficient cars mismanagement that
maybe that very well may be true but not
enough green cars GM alone offered more
gas efficient cars in Honda or Toyota as
a matter of fact they had mourn their
lineup than any car company on the
market Americans still didn't buy those
cars however as a number one selling car
in the country is still the f-150
actually out of the top 10 selling cars
in the US four of them were trucks or
SUVs with only two officially being
categorized as compacts now I know what
you're thinking but Stephen those are
just good gas cars what about the
hybrids could question American
automakers have more of those too not
only do people not by them as displayed
by all hybrids accounting for a total 2
percent of a market share but when
people do buy them it doesn't make these
companies any money when it comes to
experimental cars both Ford and GM have
admitted to having years of bleeding red
ink ahead honda hasn't fared much better
even the most successful hybrid car the
Prius is still widely believed by
analysts to be losing money on each one
sold according to the Washington Post
but if it's not the lack of green cars
that made American car makers so crappy
what was it enter the United Auto
Workers Union even under tough economic
conditions concessions are never a part
of the UAW is vocabulary fully aware of
the fact that their company will go
bankrupt under these conditions the UAW
still made sure that they received seven
weeks paid vacation each year maintain
job banks meaning that UAW workers
rarely if ever actually get fired
they're simply sent to job banks where
they are paid nearly full wages not to
work
how's that for job security get their
$74 an hour wage in both salary and
benefits compare that to the $42 an hour
for a comparable Japanese company auto
worker or even 20
six dollars in the private sector the
cost of course includes some of the most
luxurious health care coverage offered
in the planet covering not only hospital
surgical and drug coverage but
extravagances such as hearing aids and
lasik eye surgery so it's every car you
buy you're paying additional $1,200 an
employee benefits that you wouldn't be
paying with the competition
american-made all this adds up to the
average UAW worker earning a hundred and
thirty thousand a year in wages and
benefits and GM alone has had to pay
over a hundred billion dollars in
retiree health care costs in the last 15
years alone and there's no end in sight
has only to pay another 47 billion in
the near future there it is folks well
you and your family buckle down to plow
through these tough economic times the
labor of the UAW continue to live like
kings and make virtually no compromises
after all why would they if the federal
government just keeps bailing them out
and why wouldn't the federal government
keep bailing them out when it's the
unions who elect them guess just how
much of the UAW s political
contributions were donated to
conservative or republican candidates in
2008 a whopping zero percent one of the
big irony's in all of us is at liberal
environmentalists support the unions
because the unions elect them but
because the UAW labor costs are so high
it dissuades automakers from investing
in a lower profit margin smaller cars so
they instead focus on larger vehicles
and SUVs that's right folks
the UAW is bad for the environment so
the UAW runs the auto industry into the
ground and the teachers unions run
education into the ground so what
happens to Detroit as a whole
good people leave poverty Rises and so
does crime unemployment is at 28% in
Detroit right now and the murder rate is
over five times that of the national
average actually seven out of ten
murders go completely unsolved so if you
want to kill someone head on down to
Detroit not only that but the average
price of a home in Detroit is now around
fifty seven hundred dollars sound hard
to believe not when you see what many of
them look like
yeah three separations
five bottles of antifreeze any freeze is
the main ingredient used in meth freshly
eaten chip bags beer cans
Wendy's cups this is not this is not
someone is living here so we should
probably get going
at least they put up some Christmas
decorations to spread some Christmas
cheer so the people still seem to be in
good spirits
Lichter here on total family activity
fixer-upper but cozy
someone's missing a glove and down in
the basement if you want
we have a nice two-story in the Detroit
area cozy rustic oh look at this
come on come here I wonder if anything
untoward is it going on here you ever
see the movie four brothers with Mark
Wahlberg after Andre 5000 they get shot
up in the house this looks like that
post shooting look at this right here
these are fresh syringes Oh actually
look at this get a shot of all this this
whole thing look right here
we've got packs and packs of syringes
here
as you can see that actually this area
of land would have been an extra
probably 20 homes in Detroit and they've
either burned down or just been
destroyed and these huge barren sections
of land they're all over the place in
Detroit so what's actually started
popping up are things called
urban farms where people actually build
miniature farms right here in the city
to grow food for themselves and like I
said I mean it's so desolate they're
actually been bare settings in the city
of Detroit - just another problem that
they don't need here in Detroit get the
wild dogs and I got the Bears maybe
you'll see a wild dog and bear fight and
we'll get this on discovery that's what
I'm hoping for
that's my next career shift now you
might be wondering why I've shown you
this why is it necessary for you to see
a once great city brought to its knees
by government bureaucracies and powerful
unions and to you I would ask to look at
the current administration look at this
administration's promises to the
American people and compare them to the
promises of corrupt Detroit politicians
over the last 50 years they're nearly
identical Detroit has been the perfect
laboratory for leftist policies at work
for nearly half a century it's it's the
perfect vision of the left utopia that
this administration sees and when you
continue to remove free-market
principles that have made this country
great and you continue to create a state
dependent society this is very well what
America could look like in a very short
amount of time and and I think that's
important
if there's one way to describe the aura
of Detroit and would be van of
hopelessness the city citizens have been
robbed in the American Dream by
politicians and bureaucrats upstream
they've been promised the world but have
been left with this
so I asked you this is the American you
want